well outside right now we've got
beautiful skies look at the clouds just
layers of them out there seeing a little
early light that sun is on its way up
but it is fighting against the clouds
and temperatures are staying a little uh
milder than we've seen lately although
they're really pretty normal in the 40s
around the Las Vegas Valley outside the
valley a little cooler freezing it to
Indian Springs pahrump's still around
40. mid 30s in Mesquite and we've got
40s from Searchlight to Laughlin up
north though kind of a mix 20s in
Caliente teens for Ely 28 in Tonopah and
Reno is getting Northwest winds behind
that cold front so it's got the Mercury
up but they're feeling extra chilly snow
is working its way into the Northwest
with this next system winter weather
advisories and winter storm warnings
posted for a lot of the West not for us
but up North for sure wind advisories in
Southern California a lot of the country
is looking pretty easy for getting
around today for Monday but this system
will dive into the Southern Plains later
tomorrow and Wednesday cause using some
severe weather so for us it will open
the door for a cool down again clouds
will eventually be moving out we'll see
lots of sunshine that cold front is
what's going to pick up the Southwest
winds for us today and those will be up
to about 25 miles an hour for Southern
Nevada but Southeast California
advisories for winds could be 45 50
miles an hour that's from 10 a.m to 10
p.m 63 degrees today that's not bad a
little above normal those Breezy
Southwest winds behind the front tonight
oh it's going to feel cooler tomorrow
some Northerly breezes and highs in the
mid 50s Tuesday Wednesday chances for
rain showing up late Friday and best
chances for rain on Saturday with
Mountain snow slight chances left for
Sunday